so leute hamburg punkt 10 uhr lässt mit
checkout im auto in der kurve wir uns
gestern abend entschieden doch nicht
feiern zu gehen und mal ein bisschen zu
schlafen
am ende war es auch nur sechs stunden
aber das ist für uns schon lange bezogen
auf die letzten tage freiheitsgrade hier
mit dem kraftfahrzeug auf schotter mit
dem pkw auf zug wo für heute alles
vorgenommen dass wir noch mal trainieren
gehen dagegen trainings park an der elbe
eine als der glaube ich und dass wir
auch nochmal und frühstücken gehen
vielleicht schauen wir heute auch bei
einer bekannten von mir von bayer mit
einem hafen in hamburg
das ist noch nicht klar aber jetzt heißt
erst mal wach werden und in bewegung von
g
der aufzug ist jetzt einfach irgendwo
rausgeworfen wir gar nicht sein wollten
irgendeine im ersten stock von irgendwas
ich weiß nicht warum ich im erdgeschoss
gedrückt ist auch eine aufnahme zu sehen
aber irgendwie hat uns einen falschen
ort gefahren
keine ahnung warum bist du wieder runter
herr mappus ist komplett
20 minuten ca aus hamburg rausgefahren
das jetzt bei einem marie wir hier
parken kann sehr wichtig unser auto
abstellen
es geht mal rein ob die sorge dass man
frühstück
neben e mail eine fade erstes denkt bei
jedem haus du machst
der burghof du hast du
gefrühstückt wir sind jetzt auf dem weg
zu einem open air jam oder so eine art
trimm dich pfad in hamburg werden wir
ein kleines training machen
nein
rang
jetzt circa eine halbe stunde raus
gefahren ist jetzt in allermöhe
und hier ist dieser der dieser training
spot wohl auf dem schulgelände
also gehen wir gleich dahin und
trainieren okay sind wir auf dem
spielplatz ich wollte mich gerade ihm
schon beschweren
aber das warten hat sich echt gelohnt
für euch das an so viele krasse geräte
mit mimi alter schwede weiter gerade
schon zu arbeiten so jeder andere mensch
steckt sich wow spielplatz aber wir
menschen die auf dem spielplatz
trainieren sind einfach gerade voll im
himmel weil sie einfach alles gibt
heute erledigt 14 uhr 35 wir sollten
heute eigentlich mal das wort finden wo
wir schneiden können wir nicht einfach
wieder da hamburg rein aus alle mühe
alle möbel oder sogar den mountain die
dieser welt von bord mark hat uns
tatsächlich angebot das wir heute abend
noch mal in hamburg mal hier planen
können vielen dank für diese welt
disney
kleine location wechsel wir sind jetzt
bei isabel wir können hier wohl auch
unterkommen
und sie hat einen bekannten der einen
ordentlich pc hat mit irgendeiner
software zum schneiden
das heißt eventuell könnten wir heute
ist tatsächlich mal schaffen video
fertig zu machen
ich kann es kaum fassen wir machen jetzt
auf dem weg dahin ich bete dass es
irgendwas ist nicht dass es nicht wie
heißt dieses programm
ich bete dass es davon nicht final cut
ist ich bete wirklich leute tut mir das
nicht an